I was obsessed with dogs.
I wanted a dog more than anything.
My mom was allergic, so I had to start
researching alternative pets.
In my studies, I found that you can get
a gerbil for $4.99.
That's the price of raspberries.
So as a consumer, you have to ask
yourself a pretty important question.
Should I get a Driscoll's?
Or should I get a gerbil? You know what
I'm talking about. It's kind of like,
should I get a Driscoll's or a gerbil?
Should I get a Driscoll's?
I got $4.99 and I'm going to the store.
I got two options and they are a
Driscoll's or a gerbil, Should I get a
Driscoll's or a gerbil?
Should I get a Driscoll's or a gerbil?
Well, one is a breakfast berry.
The other is a two year commitment.
One you can put in a bowl.
The other you can put
in a ball. Driscoll's or a gerbil?.
Where in the name of God are gerbil's
naturally occurring?
Did Pet Co create them because I've seen
lots of foreign films that I've never
seen gerbils in the back ground.
Driscoll's or a gerbil?
Okay, so you're telling me that some
sick f*** at Petco said I'm going to
breed a mouse with a squirrel and then
I'm going to shave the tail and then
I'm going to put it on sale.
For the price, as a Driscoll's.
Driscoll's or a gerbil?
Should I get a Driscoll's or a gerbil?
What I like about Driscoll's is it's
red.
And a thousand tiny balls.
What I like about a gerbil is that its
the price of a Driscoll's. Let me get
this straight. I'm a
Child and I save up my.
Earnings for 20 minutes of chores than I
can afford a tiny new member of my
family.